I understand that you have a problem
with two of my employees
it is true that they killed one of your
Associates
it is possible they acted rationally
but on the other hand there was
provocation
the man was selling on the territory I
didn't want Tony Soprano with a little
puppy I wanted a guy who was shrewd
smart non-arrogant but was three steps
ahead of everyone else who could blend
who seemed to be one person but was
another
[Music]
the Mandalorian the structure you are
trapped in will be raised in short order
and your storied lives will come to an
unceremonious end
what do you propose
reasonable negotiation
you have something I want one of my
favorite lines
because
you can use it in life you see someone
you emulate you see someone who's really
in their own skin I always observe older
people who have nothing to prove that
living their life they're comfortable in
their own skin and that's what I want
Mafia is a very complicated guy and I
love playing him for a number of reasons
one is he's he's smart and he wants to
affect change within this particular
Galaxy and he's unable to he thinks he
can get it from outside it's such a
mythological story when you everything
you need is inside you but he feels like
that child grogu who he's after has some
DNA that's going to change things for
him possibly would change things for the
world as well so I play him in the first
two seasons as if maybe he is trying to
write all the wrongs of the universe and
the Galaxy and the world that he is in
by being in charge but he knows
everything and no one knows how so he
has a particularly
strong network of Intel which is great
but what does he really want you don't
really know except for the child I think
the part of My Success is to play
villainous characters with a human touch
who are very astute and very aware of
themselves and the world around them
[Music]
the darksaber was a wonderful thing to
wield there's only a few of us actors
who've had the opportunity to wield such
an iconic
piece of equipment sword so for me there
were there were many that I had to work
with a wonderful stunt actor who was in
the suit
um doing the stunt work for Mando uh and
and I just the whole story behind my my
my first big saber fight uh was that the
stunt guy came out and he was 20 years
younger and a really small guy and I
looked over at John I said John he went
Shrugged and I got in the corner
um and and I started to work on this
fight because I knew I'd have to do
every single frame before it looked
believable for you know a guy at my age
fighting Mando we had a bunch of
different swords sometimes the hilt
sometimes a long one sometimes one that
was lit around the end so they could
sort of CGI it in and sometimes uh it
was full weight sometimes not full
weight I chose the ones that had a full
weight because I felt like when you
wielded it you had to see it how it hit
something
um it was very very important to me to
have it be really believable so I had
practiced at home because I also have a
cape to figure out the logistics of it
with a broomstick and eventually when I
got with the dark saber it was I was
just very enthusiastic about being able
to to practice with it in the moment on
the set and to have um such a great time
playing this character with a piece of
of History that's so very iconic
[Music]
Breaking Bad
that was inspired by a stage direction
of Vince Gilligan road called hiding in
plain sight and when I read that stage
Direction in the script that they asked
me to do I was fascinated I was invited
out to a guest spot at the end of season
three of Breaking Bad and I said yes I
was very excited when I read that stage
Direction because I started to think
about who do I see from my window who
lives next door in the apartment next to
across the hall what do they really do
hey hey Gene hey harry like you know you
record your conversation to the elevator
but what do they really do who are they
really and I got obsessed with that idea
Lucy you must remember to have the salt
and pepper show this way
foreign
Diet Coke please
and five minutes of your time
so I did it one guest spot I got off the
plane they were calling to say what I do
another and I said yes to continue the
investigation I did another guest spot
and they offered me a contract and I
said let's wait because it was the end
of the season let's see what you're
thinking about for next season and they
call next season and repeated their
offer and I said I'd love to speak to
the Creator because I wanted to do
something different I felt like okay
they've had their villain of the week
and now they want a formidable villain
to play opposite
of uh Walter White uh Brian Cranston uh
who he is brilliant in that show but I
didn't want to sign on unless I was
going to do something that was atypical
and so I had to
figure out what that was
so I I say now to to many people when I
lecture colleges universities I'll sell
my children ask for what you want and so
that was a perfect example of me asking
myself what I wanted and so I asked to
speak to Vince Gilligan we had a long
conversation uh and we were on the same
page and and things took off after that
you have failed
now is Left To Me
to deal with him
if you try to interfere
this becomes a much simpler manner
I will kill your wife
I will kill your son
I will kill your
I enjoyed learning from the process of
Masters At Work Vince is a wonderful
director but I was there I think when he
first started directing uh on Breaking
Bad he had done a show prior to that
where I believe he directed but to be
able to direct your own vision is to
take matters in your own hand and really
feel and see the whole story so I was
with him at a time where he directed a
television show and at a time where he
extended that direction of shot to shot
television to filmic Visionary movie
every week and so I felt honored to be
there one episode that really stands out
for me well there are a number of them
but one in particular is box cutter I
come from the theater and so to me
um you know Harold Pinter there was a
thing called a Pinter pause where
you leave
space
sometimes that space is an interminable
amount of time
but it allows you to refocus and it gets
your attention and so I thought of this
when creating Gus so for me my
contribution was I realized I can't mess
with the words they were good how do I
slow the timing down how do I slow my
timing down
so I can hear more so I can be
contemplative so I can allow space to
affect me and so when someone would say
something to me I wouldn't answer right
away I would really hear them study them
and it it unnerves people
I mean I realize if I don't answer I
just look at you what's going on in your
head maybe did I say something wrong am
I stupid oh my God is he going to kill
me what what's happening with him right
now does he have a pulse and so I use
that in combination with my breeding
practice of yoga to allow me
to just drop down and it was a wonderful
experience for me because it helped me
to realize that the best actors don't do
anything you don't have to do anything
you got to think it but in thinking it
you want people to see it so you have to
think it and project it and it'll be
there wonderful experience in my career
and changed my life
[Music]
the boys
the boys Stan Edgar is a company man and
what makes a good villain is he's
working for somebody else you know I
mean yeah we think what makes a good
bill is he wants to take over the world
and I have some of those in my you know
Star Wars MAF Gideon life but when you
have a guy who is a company man it's
scary and so Stan Edgar frightened me a
little bit because he has no fear he has
no fear of homelander you're in a world
where you have superheroes with human
emotions who could kill you in a
heartbeat and he's like the the head of
the company who has created this
compound V so he has business venture I
don't think I see the point Stan the
point is
that you are under a misconception that
we are a superhero company we are not
what we are really is a pharmaceutical
company and you are not our most
valuable asset that would be our
confidential formula for compound V
which you man child that you are
released into the wild
bam you get the idea of big business big
politics a big government how it affects
the world I love this show the way it
happened was uh completely in a way an
accident I ran into Eric Kripke who also
was the writer of another show I did
years ago with John Favreau and so I ran
into him in the studio in in Canada when
I was doing another show uh and uh he
looked at me and took that step back and
went scratched his head and went
looked me up and down afterwards Hi how
are you what are you doing what are you
doing and I said Eric I know what you're
thinking and he said to me well if you
know what I'm thinking would you and I
said of course I would I love working
with you I said you're not gonna be able
to make a deal when that day comes text
me because they're gonna be talking to
my people and I'm not giving up and he
said you know I said text me and that
day came they tried to make a deal Gonna
Make a Deal Eric texted me I said Eric
you know come on that's you did exactly
what I told you to and I was in
eventually probably soon
the world will recognize you for the
pitiful disappointment you are
you are not worthy of my respect
you are not a God you are simply bad
product
you know they say that daughters need
the validation of their fathers and that
Sons need to be mothered and so what did
we miss in our in our lives uh what do
we miss growing up from that
relationship that needed that we needed
to be validated by so Stan Edgar
realizes that Homeland is just a big kid
and that he never got the validation
that he needed from his father and so it
becomes very very tricky he understands
that so he needs to to to be validated
by another man who says yeah you're
powerful and good and all that in return
for that Stan also feels like he's
holding on to his power he's able to
control this Loose Cannon where no one
else can you
are not a God you are simply bad product
strong I say that to myself all the time
my ego gets out of line I'm just bad
product
Better Call Saul
[Music]
look at me
from now on
you are
mine big decision for me to make I felt
like I was going to the same dance and I
hope I didn't stress anyone out and at
uh Buena Vista Productions or events uh
but I felt like uh it was a heart I
didn't I didn't want to go back in my
brain as like I can't mess with that guy
guy is done man he's history you know
what I mean he's iconic I I don't wanna
I don't wanna mess with him anymore
that I I was sitting there with beds and
I I I went okay what's the name of the
show this is like a Better Call Saul who
started Bob Odenkirk boom Rob's genius
but I went that's your place you are
part of an ensemble and you're here to
do if you choose to do
very much what you did in Breaking Bad
but then I went no don't choose that
choose to surpass that so what are your
obstacles I mean all this was in my
decision process what what can you do
differently how can you create a
different ghost it is before the time
period of Breaking Bad okay so he's more
volatile he's less controlled he all
these things went into the basket and I
said yes adding more product will
threaten the reliability of the entire
operation
mask
did daniladio approve this
I approve this
and so my work had to be even more
subtle than in Breaking Bad and so that
became a challenge to to figure out how
to grow to be the edge in Better Call
Saul and to figure out how to lend to
these two shows being bookends I contest
that if you watch Breaking Bad first and
then Better Call Saul that's great but
if you're able to watch them backwards
Better Call Saul first and then Breaking
Bad you'll be illuminated in a different
way I felt season six of Breaking Bad I
had a chance as subtle as it is to
reverse all of what I thought I would be
locked into you got a chance to see a
different Gus because I realized end of
season five into season six you had a
gus who was more vulnerable because he
there was a threat there Lalo Salamanca
and I didn't want him to be a threat
because Gus is formidable and because of
what the events of at the end of
Breaking Bad you know in a way I'm going
into Saul thinking I'm Machiavelli so
how do I allow myself the vulnerability
to have a in my armor so one scene
in Breaking Bad that you saw I don't
know if this episode nine or ten where
I'm on the elevator Johann directed it
and he he noticed I'm standing there I'm
totally still and my hands are by my
side and all you see just tapped my
finger he caught it I did this to see if
anyone would catch it standing there
completely calm stoic right but that one
little tell and he said my god do you
know you're doing that I said of course
I do he said I have to get that I have
to I have to get the camera down there I
have to get that spread right that one
little thing the work is sometimes in a
way silent uh and and very very
methodical uh and also uh it's very keen
and so everything came together in those
moments and in season six Gus's turn and
six which you know if you haven't seen
it if I don't want to have any spoilers
but you really sort of see him come out
of his shell after the threat is
disposed of so you get a chance to see
an arc that I think is um is is well
worth it and well deserved to watch this
season six of Better Call Saul
do the right thing
you're gonna pay now you're gonna pay on
layaway yeah we know where that is how
much we had 30 years you've been coming
in here at least three times a day what
are you
it's a dollar fifty stop put some
cheese in that man extra
cheese is two dollars
two dollars yeah two dollars hey you can
forget that yeah
bugging out was a journey and I I so
enjoyed working with Spike Lee and with
and do the right thing because it was
the first time that he really had an
opportunity to explore in a very deep
level the differences between us
culturally in a neighborhood setting and
to me it was the perfect balance of who
I am Italian and black and so to create
bugging out I I really had an idea that
bugging out meant well but he he he was
back man who wanted to be in a way a
revolutionary but he had no tools he
didn't have the education to carry
things out the right way so in his
little way he wanted to to create some
kind of change so Afrocentric you know
completely and and energetic and ready
to call you on your faults if you're Sal
in the pizzeria so I had this idea that
he was a loose cannon because he didn't
have the Poise or the Charisma or the
expertise to really think it all the way
through and that allowed me to have
someone who could be in a way
slightly a pest but still someone who
was pressing for equality on his own
street-level way
man ask Sal right hey hey how come get a
person from the wall here you want
Brothers on the wall get your own place
you can do what you want to do you can
put your brothers and uncles and nieces
and nephews your stepfather stepmother
whoever you want you see but this is my
Pizzeria
American Italians on a wall only well I
think that I love the scene the pizzeria
you know we're bugging out just you know
he wants to get his pizza and he wants
some extra cheese put some extra cheese
on it and and Sal is like you know uh
resistant and the attitude that Sal had
with bugging out was because he was a
pest but then when he looks up and he
sees Sinatra and Perry Como and all
these people when he he he's wondering
why he's not represented there and what
does that mean to him and it triggers
something inside of him those are very
volatile scenes in many ways because of
what happened at the end of the movie uh
between myself and and God bless him and
rest his soul Danny Aiello the Jordan
scene
was an observation of what Spike was
seeing in his neighborhood and what he
was afraid of
[Music]
yo there's a song called who stole the
soul he was afraid I think maybe I
contest that he was seeing the
soulfulness of his neighborhood go away
because of gentrification so that scene
to me was great fun with Martin Lawrence
and uh all the the the wonderful actors
in that scene John Savage to be able to
say you don't belong here you're you
know what are you doing on my block in
my neighborhood on my side of the street
I mean it's just such great dialogue
spike is a genius in terms of how he
wrote that but he also was a genius and
how he translated what he was seeing and
he was ahead of his time because you go
out there now and it's completely
gentrified and very very different than
what it was when we Shot the movie
right
with that conversation with your father
in this particular case I remember the
conversation clearly because he was
disappointed in the movie and and we
knew he had done something that was
going to make a difference or at least
open people's eyes to
um the issues that were presented but
also have them be entertained but he
didn't take to the movie because he
thought that was John Carlo is too much
cursing I said excuse me is it says
it's too much cursing I said no no
what's the point of the movie right so I
think he missed the part of the point of
the movie which had me realize I wanted
to talk to him about living in this
color skin because we had the same blood
and I don't know if I ever really
impressed upon him enough that my life
was so different because I carried this
skin my papa it thought the movie was
visual but didn't understand the issues
at hand and I was surprised because they
related to his life as well as mine
[Music]
Godfather of heart uh to me uh it's a
wonderful honor to play someone who has
lived and it's also a a huge
responsibility uh Adam Clayton Powell Jr
who I portray in Godfather of Harlem
really lived and really made incredible
uh strides for African Americans uh
during the 60s and Beyond he wrote the
Powell Amendment which was essentially
uh the Civil Rights Act and so he uh
through his relationship with Linda
Baines Johnson and JFK uh before him was
able to implement and and resist as LBJ
said to him take out the pal amendment I
have this thing passed but he wouldn't
do it because the Powell amendment was
the majority of the Civil Rights Act
that we have today so to me I I would be
haunted in my dreams if I didn't get
that right it was the first the first
what the first italian numbers Bank
you're going to enter into the
Congressional Record well how the hell
do I know
you promised the congregation one
Italian a week
hi this Jack can't you claim possum with
my identity the civil rights legislation
Adam you're invading now as much as I
hate to admit it you hit a nerve with
that sermon
and some people put names in the
suggestion box you don't have to name
names well who'd they put in the
suggestion box
that's the problem no one named any
Italians and so I read a lot of his
record
um I listened to him and the Cadence of
his speech when I first saw him I
thought this guy is white from Georgia
he kind of talked like that really you
know he was from New York you know lived
Upstate and came to Manhattan preacher
at Abyssinian Baptist Church you may
know some of his history but for me the
wonderful thing about him was not only
that he was a genius lawyer but that he
was also someone who enjoyed life
and this took some of the pressure off
me to always be as serious as I would
want to be in in in my life and in my
work I learned through the legacy of
Adam Clayton Powell Jr that he was able
to have fun he married Hazel Scott
eventually loved jazz music he smoked he
drank getting Sunday morning he was in
the Pulpit giving the sermon of his life
he was also a great orator and Statesman
and when you think about an orator or a
Statesman you wonder how they get their
point across and people really are
listening and really hear them because
it's a god-given gift to move people
from one place in their Consciousness to
another and Adam Clayton Powell did that
so for me to play him was my honor every
season is a different year in the
history of our movement and it really is
a show that's about bumpy Ellsworth
Johnson so brilliantly played by Boris
Whitaker about his journey in affecting
African-Americans in Harlem so Powell
was a new Johnson didn't agree with his
politics but knew that he was a helpful
figure in Harlem the show is about bumpy
it's about morality again about a guy
who's selling heroin to his own people
is also a slumlord in some ways but
someone who cares about his people and
will do all he can to protect him Bumpy
Johnson was was not your typical
gangster he was someone who tried to and
succeeded in struggling against the
Italians for their hold over Harlem and
so the black market no pun intended is
something that's really actively still
going today and so that is a help to the
people in certain neighborhoods because
there's certain things they can't get or
afford otherwise and so that intricate
Market is explored not only in the world
of drugs but also in the world of
politics
[Music]
Kaleidoscope I'm very proud to be a part
of this show I stepped in to this show
after having done the final season of
Better Call Saul and I had to move
quickly to jump in and
feel as if I was had enough time to
apprise myself of all that was going on
in this particular high story it's based
on a heist that took place during
Hurricane Sandy that really happened
during a hurricane uh 70 billion dollars
in unsecured bearer bonds were stolen in
this city the moment we come in the
temperature will start to rise and once
it gets above 73 degrees life in prison
got it yeah we can get by everything
else but not that
unless you've put in a back door
did you tell them you put in a back door
I put in a back door they sent me glue
to read for the first time and I read it
and I got yellow and I read that and
then I started to realize that the
structure with which they had planned to
release it was not going to be the same
I.E when I read scripts it's 101 102
they're all numbered up to eight this
was orange green blue pink yellow white
and it was all
connected so for me I was hooked because
it gave me a chance to show many
different sides of myself that you
haven't seen and to me that's an actor's
dream I love this piece because again
you can choose the order with which you
watch it so you asked me how did I feel
about that structure I was hesitant
hadn't been done how are they going to
know how people gonna know where they're
at they're all colors and people still
even today after the show has been
released they talk about did you watch
it in order well there is no order uh
you know did you watch it in
chronological order there's that word
again there's no chronological order
which gives you the opportunity to have
your imagination run wild and your
visual match up with that by trying to
figure out the story it's a heist drama
there's something left for you to do
it's to figure it out and as you're
watching you can't but help as being a
human being is to want to figure it out
like wait did you see that what just
happened there that won't get reflected
until episode yellow or blue or it won't
link up to White which you should watch
last I think the the whole idea and
structure is brilliant and the ability
for them to pull it off by all of the
connections that are there when you're
watching a second time and you see the
connections you missed the first time no
matter what order you watched it in you
will be intrigued